escuelas vacías en venezuela la falta de
combustible impide que los profesores
tomen una lancha y lleguen a la escuela
de este pueblo sobre el lago maracaibo
nosotros vamos al reto para la maestra
las maestras nos viene para cada casa
sin nada que quiera que se vuelve como
antes que el que venía del día quinta
mañana no
lo daba colegas
adaptar las tardes
la única maestra que viajaba a este
recóndito poblado dependía de los
pescadores que la llevaban pero un día
hace más de tres años dejó de venir ese
día cerró la escuela
pero no prende a la alegría
nadie está dando clase nadie
y se retiró de aquí no venimos según la
unesco la tasa de alfabetización en
venezuela está por encima del 97 por
ciento pero en este caserío el cierre de
la escuela empeoró el analfabetismo en
muchos niños que quiere estudiar no
cuento de a poco la escuela
el gobierno pretende reabrir las
escuelas hasta el 25 de octubre cerradas
tras la pandemia de kobe 19 en este
recóndito lugar del lago maracaibo sus
habitantes seguirán esperando por un
profesor que les lleve el conocimiento
en alguna de las lanchas impulsadas por
la escasa gasolina